[Music]
on this Monday night Ontario's
heart-wrenching hunger crisis this is an
emergency what the inability to afford
food is leading to people are talking to
us now about taking their own lives
unprecedented displays of dissent and
Defiance in China
Canada begins pivoting away from Trading
with Beijing
somber visit the Prime Minister honors
victims of the Saskatchewan stabbing
Rampage and the millions in funding for
an indigenous community
plus brain power I think that the
possibilities are truly endless The
Innovation allowing children to control
machines with their minds
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
lead up to Christmas is always a
financial strain on many families and
this year the pressure is as basic as it
gets the latest hunger report in Ontario
reveals the scale of the Reliance on
food banks there has been a 64 percent
increase in first-time users of Ontario
food banks since before the pandemic
Rising food prices are making it
impossible for low-income people to
afford to feed themselves and their
families and it's leading some people to
reach the breaking point Mike jourlay
has our top story tonight
as CEO of the Mississauga Food Bank
Megan Nichols deals with need every day
but that need has evolved into a crisis
the likes of which they've never seen in
the past two weeks alone she's fielded
five calls from clients seeking help in
ending their own life
so people are so desperate they're
coming here for food but then they're
asking you about assisted suicide yes
that's you're having people ask you yes
yes
that I when I say that this is an
emergency in the community
people who are living at the bottom
income percentile in our community are
talking to us now about taking their own
lives because it's too hard to be poor
any longer a new report from feed
Ontario paints a grim picture 587
000 people visited Ontario food banks a
total of 4.3 million times over the past
year a 42 percent increase since 2019.
the sixth consecutive year where there's
been a hike also worrisome one in three
Food Bank users are seeking help for the
first time and it's not just an urban
issue the food bank in akaluate reports
demand has increased 12 percent every
month this year last summer summer of
2021 we averaged between 100 to 150
meals per day right now we're seeing
between 400 to 500 meals per day it's
the same story in food banks across the
country more people are visiting more
often add Rising food prices coupled
with a decrease in donations and it's
math that doesn't work in their favor
but another way feed Ontario says
inventory that would normally last two
to three months is gone after two to
three weeks donors who would normally
give to the food bank and support
financially no longer have on that
available income to to support it and in
some circumstances
um donors have turned into actual food
bank visitors long term they'd like to
see changes to social assistance in
minimum wage but as people's desperation
grows if donations don't increase they
worry they could be Fielding even more
crisis calls in the near future
microlyte Global News Toronto
now to the extraordinary unrest on the
streets in China public protest there is
swiftly quashed by the communist regime
and tonight there's a heavy police
presence in Beijing and other cities an
attempt to keep people from expressing
their anger officers were seen looking
at individual phones there are reports
they're checking them for vpns and
deleting images so they can't be posted
to social media support for the protests
is spreading people in Hong Kong have
used white sheets of paper and flowers
as a sign of solidarity and around the
world demonstrations have also taken
place the protesters in China want an
end to the coveted lockdowns but are
also demanding the rule of law freedom
of the press even the downfall of
Chinese president Xi Jinping as Mike
Armstrong reports it is testing xi's
ability to control the population
oh
this is different there are protests in
China but not like this
they happen they're local maybe a
demonstration over pensions at a plant
or pollution these protests are National
we have a sense now that people have the
same grievance against the regime and
that's new
over China's drastic zero covet policy
turned first to frustration and now to
anger where most of the world has moved
on from lockdowns they're still as rigid
as ever for the Chinese one person
contracts covet in an apartment the
whole building can be confined the
nightmare stories have been growing for
months from suicides to deaths in a bus
that overturned carrying people to
quarantine
[Music]
latest story is a fire last week 10
people were killed and the lockdown is
being blamed the reports people couldn't
get out quickly enough because they were
confined and reports firefighters were
delayed by lockdown fencing it's hard to
know if either is true people identify
with the victims the fire that happened
in olympi in the westernmost part of the
country has resonated with people who
live in Shanghai at the other end
the Chinese government Monday called the
reports about the fire disinformation
smears spread on social media
now traditional media in China is
tightly controlled there are no mentions
of the protests but word has gotten out
on social media posts are deleted by the
government if they're about the protests
but that takes time if they're up even
for minutes they can be seen
proof that has happened is in a symbol
that's being spread blank sheets of
paper now represent Defiance in cities
across the country and with Chinese
artists outside the country some
analysts say the government can't let
this go on for long well it's highly
dangerous I think we haven't really seen
the repressive apparatus fully engaged
at this point but unfortunately I I
think that is what we're going to
observe in the days and weeks to come
covid rules may be the biggest part of
what's going on but there are also some
openly criticizing the Communist party
and leader Xi Jinping
the government could let some of the
pressure out by relaxing coveted rules
but China has an aging population low
vaccination rates and a less effective
domestic vaccine opening up would mean
other problems
Mike Armstrong Global News
the unrest is having Ripple effects the
stock market took a hit today investors
worried about the Chinese economy and
how the government will react to the
protests oil prices have also dropped
they're now at an 11-month low in part
because of weak demand in China which is
the world's largest oil importer much
less on what happens there and the idea
the trade with the West would lead to
social and political reform in China is
now seen as naive Canada is taking a new
approach looking at China as an
increasingly disruptive Global power
Mackenzie gray explains Canada's
strategy to shift away from Chinese
dominance a harsh rebuke of Canada from
Beijing
a Foreign Affairs Ministry spokesperson
saying Canada's new indo-pacific
strategy is full of ideological bias
that makes unfounded accusations against
China
the Liberals are no stranger to Chinese
complaints president Xi Jinping lectured
Justin Trudeau this month at the G20 for
sharing details of an earlier
conversation another sign of a faltering
relationship with Canada's second
largest trading partner China will have
more respect for Canada when we have a
bigger presence among its neighbors and
are seen to be players and making
important contributions a central part
of this new plan isolating China who the
government now says is a disruptive
Global power the opposition is critical
of the lack of specific details well you
know my biggest concern is not whether
or not it goes far enough my biggest
concern is whether or not there's
actions that follow these words the
Liberals have put up 2.3 billion dollars
over five years to execute their plan
and one of the biggest Financial
commitments is boosting the Canadian
military presence in the indo-pacific
Canada will now send three frigates to
the region but a senior government
official told reporters today they don't
know when in 2023 that will happen thank
you and to fill the space economically
the Liberals hope to increase trade with
another superpower India
we're targeting completing an economic
partnership agreement as their key goal
but it's a deal that Canada has been
trying to complete since 2010 with
negotiations last taking place over five
years ago India is an incredibly complex
Market
and our relationship with India's fraud
at the present time and is difficult
Chinese interference in Canada is
another important issue after global
news first reported that China allegedly
spent nearly a quarter million dollars
to fund 11 different candidates in the
2019 election Canada's foreign
ambassador to China believes the focus
on Chinese interference is important but
action is needed Canadians expect more
in terms of what the government is going
to do concretely to prevent interference
in the political system asked how they
would know if the new strategy would be
successful a senior government official
told reporters today audible would gauge
success based on strength and deepen
relations with friendly indo-pacific
countries but couldn't provide any
concrete benchmarks to measure that
Donna all right Mackenzie gray and
Ottawa thanks the former Hydro Quebec
employee charged with spying for China
was released on bail today 35 year old
Yu Shang Wang was arrested November 14th
and has been held in police custody
since then he's the first person in
Canada charged with economic espionage
under the security of Information Act he
also faces three charges for fraudulent
use of a computer obtaining a trade
secret and breach of trust Wang was
released on two hundred thousand dollars
bail and had to turn in his passport he
must carry a cell phone with geolocation
turned on at all times
prime minister Justin Trudeau spent the
day on the James Smith Cree Nation in
Saskatchewan a community that has much
healing to do after the mass stabbing
there in September
prime minister visited the graves where
some of those killed were laid to rest
he was then welcomed in a grand entry
ceremony and met with leaders and
community members 12 people died
including the suspect who took his own
life in police custody among those he
killed was his own brother 18 others in
the close-knit community were injured
during the attacks on September 4th the
horrific crime sparked new calls for
more Community Support addictions
counseling and indigenous-led policing
Nathaniel Dove is on the James Smith
Cree Nation tonight Nathaniel the Prime
Minister promised funding what did he
offer and what was the reaction
Donna ever since the attacks as you
point out there have been calls for
change to prevent anything similar from
ever happening again today the Prime
Minister announced around 60 million
dollars 20 million of that will go
towards a program to help end violence
against indigenous women and girls
around two and a half will go towards
providing addictions access to
addictions uh treatment for that is
traditionally grounded in First Nations
beliefs and the largest amount 60
million will go towards a new treatment
center
we'll invest 40 million dollars over six
years to build a new Wellness Center
here in the community and to repurpose
the
existingo lodge to address immediate
needs
today's announcement will enable James
Smith cremation to develop and design
the programs that best serve the needs
of its members
I asked an addictions counselor here at
James Smith what he thought of the
announcement and not just an addictions
counselor Daryl Burns lost his sister in
the attack Gloria Lydia Burns he grew
very emotional when I asked him he's was
saying finally people here at James
Smith cremation and hopefully in other
First Nations can finally start passing
on something good to their children and
grandchildren not just the hurt and the
harm that they've that they've learned
that they've Incorporated through
alcohol and addictions he says though
there's a lot more work to be done this
funding expires uh it was only good for
four to six years there's a lot more
work to be done further past that for
the harm caused by residential schools
now I asked Chief Wally Burns for
timelines with regards to the wellness
center and when this will start he
doesn't have any firm dates on that yet
but he did say progress starts today
Donna oh all right Nathaniel Dove on the
James Smith Cree Nation in Saskatchewan
thanks
Canada's newest member of the Supreme
Court and first indigenous justice has
been formally welcomed onto the
country's top Court Michelle obonsoan is
a bilingual franco-ontarian and an
Abenaki member of the odonik First
Nation she says her journey has not been
an easy one but it's been meaningful and
rewarding and she hopes she's setting an
example
I hope that my journey to this court
will inspire young women to pursue their
dreams
I am a big believer that if you have a
goal work hard and never give up you can
make things happen and Achieve those
dreams
abonson's appointment to the Supreme
Court has been praised by indigenous
leaders Nationwide as a step towards
reconciliation and balancing the
membership of the Court
on a wing and a prayer coming up the
small plane dangling in high voltage
power lines for hours
[Music]
Hawaii's Mauna Loa volcano the world's
largest active volcano has woken up it
is erupting for the first time since
1984. the U.S Geological Survey says the
volcanic activity began late Sunday
night the lava flows are contained right
now posing no immediate threat to nearby
communities scientists are waiting to
see if it develops into a rift Zone
eruption which should make it
significantly easier for magma to emerge
a few frightening hours in Maryland when
a small plane crashed into high voltage
power lines and then dangled for six
hours the pilot and passenger were alive
but hanging about 30 meters in the air
emergency crews had to make sure there
was no electricity in the lines before
using a crane to rescue them both people
were taken to hospital with trauma
injuries and hypothermia and power was
out to a hundred and twenty thousand
customers
an avowed white supremacist has pleaded
guilty to 10 counts of first-degree
murder for the mass shooting in May at a
supermarket in a predominant late black
neighborhood of Buffalo New York police
say Peyton General Gendron who is 18
years old at the time left a racist
Manifesto online before the attack and
he live streamed the shooting on social
media he also pleaded guilty to
attempted murder and domestic terrorism
charges he faces a mandatory sentence of
life in prison without parole he's still
facing more than two dozen federal
charges some which carry the death
penalty
[Music]
discrimination allegation ahead of Human
Rights complaint against the Vancouver
Canucks launched by a former employee
[Music]
a former member of the Vancouver Canucks
coaching staff is alleging she was
discriminated against she was fired in
September and has now filed a complaint
with the BC human rights tribunal nitu
garcha reports
the Canucks have had their fair share of
challenges on the ice this season and
now the franchise is facing a very
different problem off the ice the
Canucks were putting a lot of pressure
on me to not go public this is Rachel
Dory former Canucks analyst and
assistant video coach after less than a
year the team parted ways with her in
September leaving many wondering why
there was no reason given for my
dismissal publicly now Dory has filed a
complaint with the BC human rights
tribunal alleging she was fired because
of her mental illness and physical
disability pointing to a heart condition
she suffers from and claiming she
disclosed her struggles with anxiety
attacks and depression to the Canucks
while interviewing for the job I want
people who have mental illnesses and
physical disabilities to not be looked
down upon dory's claims are targeted at
a high profile and respected executive
Canucks assistant GM Emily castonguay
Dory says she was promoted but before
the Canucks organization announced it a
Porter and friend of hers wrote this
news article about her promotion the
article features praise from Canuck's
head coach Bruce Boudreau Dory posted
the article on her personal social media
and claims she was then called to a
meeting with castongay who Dory alleges
told her you're not important enough to
be cared about and I don't know if you
have what it takes to do the job
mentally stories of racism in hockey
stories of sexual assault in hockey
there's just too many stories in a
statement cast on gay says dory's claims
are quote absolutely not true and her
allegations of what I said to her are
false and inaccurate the Canucks
organization also issuing a statement
saying we acted in good faith and abided
by our contractual obligations both
during and after her employment I don't
think anybody expected uh
Emily or the Canucks to come out and say
yeah we did it
um so for me this was kind of par for
the course Dory who also spent a year
and a half as a video analyst with the
New Jersey Devils is also asking the
tribunal to order the Canucks to
compensate her nitu Garcia Global News
Vancouver
here's a sign of the times
Merriam-Webster has chosen gaslighting
as the word of the year it has according
to the dictionary become the favored
word for the perception of deception
gaslighting is the actor practice of
grossly misleading someone especially
for one's own Advantage lookups of the
word increased almost two thousand
percent this year compared to 2021. the
word comes from a 1938 British stage
play later adapted into a movie a
deceitful husband drives his wife to
near Insanity by convincing her she's a
kleptomaniac and that she has only
imagined The Sounds in the attic and the
dimming of the gaslights in their house
turning thoughts into action next how
mind control technology is transforming
lives
[Music]
the ability to control electronic
devices with your mind still sounds like
the stuff of Science Fiction but the
ability to detect electrical activity in
the brain through the scalp and to
control it is beginning to transform
medicine and change society in profound
ways Heather urich's West reports on
what researchers in Alberta are doing to
help children with complex physical
needs operate all sorts of devices with
just a thought
can you make it go a year ago Claire
Sonnenberg entered a new world
one where she can turn on a blender or
play a game using her thoughts alone it
was one of the best feelings I think I I
could have had for her and her smile
just said it all Claire was born with
Cerebral Palsy she's not able to speak
and a lot of movements are challenging
as well but thanks to brain computer
interface technology and the think to
switch a new device developed by
researchers at the universities of
Calgary and Alberta Claire's mind is
learning to operate new games and
devices all the time Claire hem has a
mix master and she can use it so she can
she does all the mixing the boys add the
ingredients she can do pasta making she
plays video games the technology
translates thoughts into action using a
headset placed on a child's head when
someone like Claire thinks about a
movement in her case kicking her foot a
part of her brain is activated the
sensor reads the message and the think
to switch device Acts activates a
connected application like a light
switch or a command in a video game it
can control many many things
the assistive technology world have
created a lot of switches after toys and
it can even be used for pound Mobility
while it may seem like science fiction
BCI or brain computer interface
technology is nothing new but its
applications for children with complex
physical needs have come a long way in
the last decade alone for One headsets
are now widely available commercially at
a cost of about a grand with
applications like the think to switch
letting kids practice these new brain
skills every day part of what's exciting
about working with kids is that they
have the ability to really
learn this technology in a way that you
and I might struggle some with and it
gives them opportunities to develop in a
lot of ways that they see their their
peers developing when we can can you
know communicate through Play and games
it's a it's a new world for us and with
hopes for this technology to help Claire
with mobility and communication in the
future the possibilities in this new
world seem Limitless Heather your ex
West Global News Calgary
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is absolutely Ontario we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]